[Music]
what's going on everybody Ian Carter's
here on behalf of Pro Football Focus
representative beat our fantasy thanks
again for joining us as we always do
this on Thursday afternoons happy week
nine got a lot of great stuff to talk
about today but first want to go through
some of these key entries that broke
really in the last hour or so
unfortunately Saints wide receiver
Michael Thomas has missed a bunch of
time recently and he is going to miss a
lot more on IR he's going to undergo toe
surgery we'll miss the rest of the
season so really unfortunate you know we
saw Thomas unfortunately enter the
season banged up after having some
August issues he scores three touchdowns
in the first two weeks just couldn't
quite get back out there on the field so
we'll see if Jarvis Landry ever gets
back in action but for now the Chris a
Lobby and Alvin Kamara show in New
Orleans should be continuing also got to
keep an eye on another wide receiver
unfortunately not going to be playing
any more football this season we're shot
baby with that foot injury we'll miss
the remainder of the year so Devin
Duvernay someone that yeah it's been a
little bit erratic this is a passing
game that throws to his tight ends more
than any other group in the league but
without being statement in the picture
Devin Duvernay does suddenly become
someone likely available on a lot of
those Waiver Wires and these can be
tough to keep out at the top 36 as the
clear-cut number one wide receiver in
this Ravens offense so we got whatever's
left of the Sean Jackson coming back
this week that's right he is on the
Ravens at this point but Devin Duvernay
should be Lamar Jackson's number one or
number two pass game option more weeks
than nine it really could be number one
here if Mark Andrews is going to miss
time with the shoulder injury
unfortunately he wasn't able to practice
on Thursday and this is a tricky
situation everyone Saints Ravens are on
Monday night there's a lot of moving
pieces here if Mark Andrews is going to
miss this game with a shoulder injury
all of a sudden Isaiah likely you know
the meme you guys have all seen
everywhere likely 80 make whatever joke
you want about it truly talented rookie
tight Endo I mean pff's highest grade
tight end throughout the preseason we
saw him come in last week against the
Buccaneers once Andrews did start
missing time and all he did was ball out
so with Isaiah likely potentially
stepping in for Mark Andrews he would be
immediately in the positions top top six
fantasy options given both Andrews and
Bateman will be out of this offense we
just need to remember it is on Monday
Night Football so you need to have a
backup plan in case guys like Mark
Andrews are going to get back in Action
similar sentiment with this backfield
Gus Edwards unfortunately not practicing
either so yeah Kenyan Drake does have
the potential to get 10 to 15 carries if
we are going to take Gus out of the
picture but it's on Monday Night final
note here is that Jonathan Taylor's
still not practicing with the knee
injury so Dion Jackson guys keep
listening to me be our fantasy it's a
great day to be great but you got a cell
phone for a reason go pick up Dion
Jackson if he's available on that wafer
wire because if Taylor is going to miss
time looking a lot like the guy that
gave us that PPR rb1 overall finish all
the way back in week six
all right guys welcome to BR Fantasy
Live presented by State Farm have an
awesome show on top for you guys today
looking at strength of schedule from now
to the start of the fantasy football
playoffs it's by again week six teams
out there I'm buying it's going to keep
on keeping on really until we do get to
the fantasy football playoffs so I
wanted to try to get an idea of who has
the easiest road ahead get into the
fantasy playoffs and who has the hardest
hopefully will help inform us and make
some good waiver wire trade decisions
whatever else we're trying to do to
improve that team before the playoff
stretch so Blood Sweat and Tears wanted
to sum the charts I got going for you
guys today but hey it works out and
hopefully will make us all smarter so
the charts you're going to see here
moving forward the easiest way I can
explain it guys blue is good red is bad
I used to do green and red but that is
not easy on the odds for colorblind
people so again blue good red bad I've
ordered them accordingly so at the top
of these charts you're going to see the
easiest schedules and at the bottom of
the charts you're going to see the
hardest schedules basically went through
everything single team's upcoming
opponents and I looked at how many PPR
fantasy points they've allowed to each
position so we're going to go through
quarterback running back wide receiver
and tight end pointing out the easiest
schedules first and then the hardest
schedules next so I'll give some quick
Refreshers along the way it's really not
that complicated and again I will
clearly Define the easiest and hardest
schedule so with that let's get into the
quarterback position and as you can see
on the top of our handy dandy charts all
blue is a good thing and we're seeing a
lot of it for the five quarterbacks and
Trevor Lawrence Justin Herbert Russell
Wilson Matthew Stafford and Joe burrow
now I get it guys like Justin Herbert
and Joe burrow they're going to be in
your starting qb1 spot even if there's a
fire every single time regardless of the
matchup and they should be those are
great offenses even better quarterbacks
and we just don't need to worry about
matchups the same sort of way now it's
great that they're going to have easier
games maybe they are going to blow up a
little more often but the bigger
question marks are for guys like Trevor
Lawrence Russell Wilson and especially
now Matthew Stafford who was one I want
or who I want to really focus on here
because let's face it this Rams offense
we can look at the Packers we can look
at the Buccaneers we can look at the
Rams these have been the three most
disappointing units in the NFC and with
the Rams in particular I just don't
exactly know what their way out of this
is because this is a new low for the
Sean McVeigh leg group we thought we hit
rock bottom in 2020 Jared goff's final
season there this was just a 22nd ranked
scoring offense and they ranked 11th in
yards I mean incredibly enough those are
the two lowest marks of Sean mcveigh's
tenure since he arrived there in 2017.
one year after another this has been a
great offense and then they got back to
doing that last season seventh in points
and Ninth and yards guys through eight
weeks this year this Rams offense 28th
in points and 30th in yards it's been a
terrible unit similar in Denver it's not
that the ramps have been mediocre
they've arguably been one of the single
worst offenses in the entire league and
it's not just on Stafford but it
certainly hasn't helped Stafford's
counting numbers we saw plenty of years
in Detroit that Stafford was just fine
putting up big numbers on bad football
teams that hasn't been the case here
last year Matthew Stafford how did
League High 17 interceptions but he also
threw 41 touchdowns this year he's once
again on Pace to hit that interception
Mark he's on Pace for 19 in fact on Pace
for just 17 passing touchdowns though
week two he threw three touchdowns
that's the only game all season that he
had more than one only one game with
even more than 275 passing yards as well
so with Matthew Stafford and Company as
much as I would like to think pff's 30th
ranked offensive line will magically
improve and that Alan Robinson will
start being the guy we all drafting him
to me I drafted to be at the end of the
day everyone I just don't think anyone
on this offense other than Cooper cup is
going to give us a consistent fancy
goodness so it's a good schedule if we
do see the Rams start fixing some of
these underlying problems maybe we can
get behind Stafford and Company but out
of that group again Lawrence Herbert
Russ Stafford and burrow I had the most
concern about Matthew Stafford actually
taking advantage of that easy schedule
on to the hardest as we scroll down our
handy dandy charts you can now see these
guys are full of red moving forward in
weeks 9 through 14 before those fantasy
playoffs get going so the top five
quarterbacks who are going to have a
really tough time making ends meet in
Fantasyland moving forward Ryan
Tannehill or Malik Willis you know not
obviously guys that aren't exactly on
the fantasy radar as it is anyway but
don't expect things to get much easier
for them also looking at two at Taco
Bell Loa Dak Prescott Jacob Sean Watson
soon enough and finally Jalen hurts so
look hurts and even wants to Sean Watson
is out there those are guys that just
the manner in which they run the ball
like they're just pretty much built in a
fantasy friendly Factory just to be guys
that we want to have out there so
jalenhurst can be playing the best
defense in the league every single week
still going to be awfully difficult to
keep out of the positions top three the
bigger question I think is what to make
of two attacker by Loa and this Miami
Dolphins passing game because they've
been really freaking good Whenever two
has been out there this year in fact
they're 5-0 in the 5G games that Tua has
been able to start and finish on the
season and the offenses accordingly been
one of the better and more efficient
groups in the league specifically top
five of the EPA per play and yards per
play but this stretch isn't going to be
the easiest they get the Bears the
Browns the Texans the 49ers and the
Chargers now 49ers and Chargers will can
definitely give their secondaries a lot
of love there these other teams like the
Bears like the Texans and even the
Browns to a lesser extent not the most
dangerous defenses but they've been bad
enough against the run that teams
haven't had to keep their foot down in
the passing game that's where things
change for this Miami Dolphins offense
Mike McDaniel and Company top 10 pass
play rate the season and non-garbage
time situations and let's face it this
offense rides through Tua Tyree kill and
Jalen waddle far ahead of anything going
on in the running game so yeah we will
see an under throw here and there but
honestly guys when Tyree kill is 20
yards behind the defense already it's
okay if he has to run 10 yards back the
other direction to catch the ball it
hasn't impacted the effectiveness of
this passing game two of this season
number one adjust the completion rate
onto those 20 plus yards downfield
second in yards for attempt six in PFF
passing grade pick a stat any stat and
it's going to tell you this Miami
Dolphins offense particularly the
passing game is an awfully Elite unit so
two attacker below and not the easiest
schedule down the stretch but I do
believe this offense as a whole led by
Mike McDaniel is good enough to keep on
keeping on anyway
appreciate all you guys in the chat
before we get on to running back want to
give out a few start sets whatever else
is on your mind so from at twipz Mike
Evans versus the Rams or a Monroe Saint
Brown versus Green Bay I hate slash love
when you guys give me these close
questions because you put me on the spot
but it is a great problem to have and I
have a Monroe Saint Brown and full PPR
exactly one spot ahead of Mike Evans so
I was also pouring over this very same
predicament myself making my rankings on
Tuesday but at the end of the day a
manra we saw the first two weeks of the
year with TJ Hawkinson and Swift also in
the picture that he was still capable of
putting up Elite numbers even as the
non-focal point of the passing game
guess what we're right back to where we
were in the second half of last season
DeAndre Swift is banged up TJ Hawkinson
now resides in Minnesota and all of a
sudden you look at the Sun God and it's
awfully difficult to see him getting
anything less than 10 targets per game
so give me a Monroe Saint brown but
again very good problem to have you
better have multiple other top 10 wide
receivers for this to even be a question
from Mikey Fox what I trade Keenan Allen
for James Robinson and Dion Jackson
that's a tough one if you're set at wide
receiver already which if you're making
this trade you know it certainly seems
like you're moving in that direction I
don't hate it unfortunately Keenan Allen
the word out of Campus is hamstring got
worse during the bye week like what how
has that even happen out here and at
least with James Robinson and Deon
Jackson you're getting guys that may be
useful in the flex but at a minimum both
Robinson and Jackson one injury away
from being on the top of every single
waiver wire article out there and in
Dion's case already kind of had that
injury happen with Jonathan Taylor
unable to practice on Wednesday or
Thursday so again matters about the
roster but if you are really deep at
wide receiver and it's a situation where
Keenan might not even be in your
starting lineup once he's healthy I do
think that's a reasonable enough trade
to make
all right guys looking ahead now easiest
and hardest schedules at the running
back position again easiest way I can
explain these charts blue is good red is
bad we have them sorted so the easiest
schedules are going to be at the top and
the hardest schedules are going to be at
the bottom so with that said running
back seeing all kinds of Blue from weeks
9 to 14 and before we get into the
fantasy football playoffs Rahim moster
with the dolphins Josh Jacobs with the
Raiders the Falcons backfield please get
back our one true king Cordero Patterson
he is eligible to return this week
hopefully he's ready to go for the
stretch run Travis ctm with the Jaguars
and the Bears backfield consisting of
David Montgomery and Khalil Herbert so
similar to quarterbacks like if they're
just match-ups at the end of the day so
we don't want to let that completely
override everything else on the table
but we'll take it easier matchup versus
a hard match up we'll take the easier
one every single time I do have a
slightly higher concern though with
Raheem mostert and the Dolphins now I
just said a lot of good things about Tua
and this passing game not quite as many
good things to say about this Russian
attack though just in terms of usage all
those same things that helped me feel
good about Tua overcoming you know his
upcoming schedule I do worry about what
Raheem most was it's a top 10 offense
and there could be a bit of a Changing
of the Guard going on I don't think that
Jeff Wilson is going to straight up take
Raheem moster's job that said guys
Raheem mostert not exactly you know the
Pinnacle of players proving that they
can play 17 games and not get injured
career high touches is just 151 and
honestly I don't think Miami's really
doing a great job of keeping him healthy
my name is Ian Hardison I am not a
doctor I don't know why Raheem moster is
out there on kick returns every single
week this year though so it just seems
like Mike McDaniel and Company playing
with fire and why did they bring in Jeff
Wilson they went out of their way to
bring him in when they still have miles
Gaskin and South and achman if they
really didn't care about the backup
running back spot so Jeff Wilson once
again fantastic handcuff regardless of
what happens because he no longer has to
deal with guys like Debo Samuel Powell
juice check making a two-headed
backfield in reality more of like a
three or four person committee but I do
think that he could be a bit more of a
Thor in the side of rahimosa so the
schedule is fantastic I mean this week
against the Bears definitely start
Raheem moster and if nothing changes
then fantastic we're feeling good about
Raheem moster moving forward it's just
more so of a hey if you have an extra
bench spot don't be afraid to go grab
Jeff Wilson suddenly a tier one handcuff
and keep an eye on any potential
opportunity for this backfield to become
more of a two-man split so for now we're
loving Raheem moster definitely don't
you know take him out of that starting
lineup just realize this Jeff Wilson
Factor could make things interesting
because Chase Edmonds acting as one of
the worst running backs in the league in
all honesty we knew he was the clear-cut
number two behind Raheem mostert we
don't have that same sense of assurance
with Jeff Wilson for now guys looking at
the hardest schedules now facing the
running back position all sorts of red
now the easiest way to overcome a tough
matchup is through fantasy friendly
volume so when we see at the very bottom
of the list this New Orleans Saints
backfield that's not ideal for album
Kamara but again this is fantasy points
per game against running backs full PPR
scoring guys like Kamara who are
possible to catch behind the seven
passes per game which really with Andy
Dalton under Center has been the case
far more weeks than not this season I am
not worried about matchups nearly as
much as only so many running backs that
have the sort of fantasy friendly volume
the album Kamara does I don't care who
he is playing on a weekly basis when you
have that many potential Targets on your
plate that said the Jets backfield
Dalvin cook Patriots backfield and
Jonathan Taylor also facing just you
know objectively tough schedules here
down the stretch as we enter into the
fantasy playoffs
obviously out of all those guys the one
really starting to change things is
Jonathan Taylor in Indy because the
man's banged up and has also been some
shuffling in his own backfield the Colts
went ahead and sent Naim Hines over to
Buffalo thanks for telling us that Naim
Hines was going to be a great fantasy
asset back in March uh Frank Reich
people don't forget on that one but with
Jonathan Taylor it's obviously been
incredibly disappointing for any of you
that did use the number one over pick on
him and as much as I would you know
because I was someone I said you should
draft Christian McCaffrey at number one
I can't really Victory lap that Jonathan
Taylor is my rb2 and that sure hasn't
come to fruition either so it's one of
those situations where I don't think
anybody saw this Myriad of issues
plaguing Jonathan Taylor to this extent
I mean my goodness guys last week
Christian McCaffrey scored 40.8 PPR
points and that three touchdown Master
Class where he threw one caught one and
ran for one 40.8 PPR points since week
two Jonathan Taylor only has 43 PPR
points so it's just been a different
game for the guy and again it has has
been any one single Factor but it also
hasn't been any one good positive to
help him overcome all this so starting
off Jonathan Taylor continues to deal
with an ankle injury that has kept them
out of practice and back-to-back weeks
and shout out to my friend fantasy
points doctor Edwin porris also does
some work with the Minnesota Twins truly
a smart guy because again I don't know
what I don't know what an echo injury is
going to be doing to these guys so Edwin
did tell us that this is an issue where
it might not keep him out of the game
it's actually a lateral Sprain and he
Edwin says that rehab resting brace
Taylor has a chance to play this week
the problem is everyone said don't be
surprised if he looks like late season's
take one from last season these guys are
playing through the pain and it sucks
that we gotta you know potentially rein
back the expectations for anyone's idea
of a top two running back entering the
season but it's not just the pain he's
playing through the pain in the 30th
ranked scoring offense I mean last
season Jonathan Taylor had 26 carries
inside the five yard line this year he
has four and you also got to keep in
mind this offensive line Quentin Nelson
and Company really living more on
reputation than anything at this point
this is the first season they have ever
ranked outside of pff's top 10 run
blocking units under Frank Reich and
it's not like their 11th or 12th 30th
season just 1.1 yards before contact for
Kerry that Mark ranks 25th so Jonathan
Taylor again it's a tough schedule for
him moving forward and last year's
Jonathan Taylor in a good scoring
offense with a great offensive line yeah
I'd feel good about him overcoming it
but all those factors on top of him
being on less than 100 percent
unfortunately I think we're gonna have
to get used to treating Jonathan Taylor
far more as an rb2 as opposed to Locked
In top five rb1 that he's been
throughout most of the early part of his
career
from the chat at little slack do I trade
CMC oh we got a blockbuster deal here
everyone CMC Godwin Mills and Garrett
Wilson for Russ Kittle a Monroe and
James Connor I'm gonna lean quickly to
the CMC side I believe that Christian
McCaffrey and Chris Goblin could
honestly be the two best pieces of this
trade and at that point you know you
might as well just be happy to take the
two shining blue chip pieces of it we
obviously have seen CMC in everything he
can do with as part of the lead back and
a Kyle shanahan-led offense but don't
sleep on Chris Goblin I mean since he
returned full time from the knee and
hamstring injury in week four only
Tyreek Hill has more targets than Chris
Goblin during that stretch and guess
who's tied for third Mike Evans like the
problems that we thought we were going
to have in this Buccaneers offense was
there was going to be too many parties
really to condense any amount of targets
around one or two individual guys but
Julio Jones been in and now the lineup
of the knee injury Russell Gage is
dealing with the hamstring obviously
Gronk was actually serious about that
retirement we haven't seen a tight end
step up in his absence so both Chris
Godwin and Mike Evans I think could have
some serious booms down the stretch if
and when Tom Brady in this passing game
finally start to play with a little bit
more consistency
from App probably hi good for you start
Gino or Justin Fields man another one of
these questions where it shows right
next to each other I do have Gino as my
qb9 Fields as my qb10 this week I just
think that with Geno Smith even last
week I know the counting numbers weren't
there but Tyler Lockett and barquis
Goodman dropped touchdowns and Lockett
had another potential touchdowns in his
hands and just out of bounds so Justin
Fields the rushing floor is fantastic at
this point I mean 40 rushing yards per
game pretty much ever since week two or
week three so Fields it's fantastic he
has I think actually two more Rush
attempts than Lamar Jackson on the
season it's not that dissimilar the
problem is like Lamar we don't have much
of a guarantee through the passing game
so Fields very high floor four straight
top 12 finishes but I do think Gino in
what's inexplicably been a top five
scoring offense and absolutely lethal
passing game he gets a nod from me this
week and what I think has a much better
chance of shooting out between the
Seahawks and the Cardinals
all right guys over at wide receiver now
as we can see on the top of our charts
that again Blood Sweat and Tears went
into this that the red format is
actually just my own blood it's not even
an actual heat map going on here but
we'll focus on the blue and the easy
schedules right now for the wide
receivers moving forward and it's a
couple groups at the top that could use
the help the Jacksonville Jaguars again
talked about Trevor Lawrence earlier
really having a nice stretch coming up
and it makes sense that his receivers do
as well Cincinnati Bengals Denver
Broncos Los Angeles Chargers and the New
Orleans Saints also standing out as key
groups so with a lot of these guys the
Saints as we talked about earlier
Michael Thomas being gone we know a
Lobby is going to be the standout with
the Chargers is basically who can be
healthy enough to go take advantage of
having Justin Herbert under Center and
we already talked about Trevor Lawrence
and Company a little bit so I want to
focus here on the Bengals and
it's a situation where like do they even
need this help because when Joe burrow
and Company are healthy they tend to be
able to ball out against just about
anybody but coming up here from week
nine two week 14 they get the Panthers
then a buy and the Steelers Titans
Chiefs and Browns right up into the
fantasy football playoffs so even
without Jamar chasing the picture guys
you're gonna have an awfully difficult
time keeping Tyler Boyd and T Higgins
out of those starting lineups so T
Higgins this year has scored a touchdown
and or surpassed 90 receiving yards and
all but two of his full games so I know
last week we didn't get the explosion we
were hoping for but man when both him
and Boyd still managed to find the end
zone and an offense more condensed than
ever around them you know I don't think
we should be too harsh on a one-week
sample size without Jamar Chase and and
Tyler Boyd's case we honestly have a far
larger sample size of what he's able to
do without one of Higgins or chase in
the lineup remember Chase was not on
this first version of the Bengals
offense when Joe burrow was a rookie and
not really allowed Boyd to thrive he has
now actually played 4 14 games without
one of Higgins or Jamar Chase but with
Joe Burl under Center and in those games
guys seven top 20 finishes out of 14
games and nine top 28 finishes he's only
had two true Duds where he's finished
outside of fantasy's top 36 receivers in
those games so really what boy his floor
is already pretty high without one of
these guys in the picture and his
ceiling has really gone untapped and I
don't think it's being properly weighed
by the fantasy Community as a whole so
both Tyler Boyd and T Higgins especially
going to be awfully difficult to keep
out of those top 20 fantasy wide
receivers for however long Chase is out
and guess what when Chase is back he's
from our freaking Chase joins Justin
Jefferson Tyreek Hill Stefan Diggs
Cooper cup and DeAndre Hopkins only wide
receivers averaging at least 20 PPR
points per game this season so it's been
a little bit of an up and down season
for the Spangles passing game don't be
surprised that they really started
catching their stride right at the most
important time before those fantasy
playoffs get going
on the other side of things there are
some hard stretches coming up for some
offenses that we do have awfully fancy
relevant players and specifically Dallas
Cowboys standing out as the offense with
the toughest remaining strength of
schedule going up into the fantasy
football playoffs for their wide
receivers the Las Vegas Raiders also not
looking good it's not like they freaking
needed this after that goose egg last
week also the Eagles the Lions and the
Titans as well so hey with the Lions we
got the Sun God and Monroe Saint Brown I
think he'll be just fine particularly
with some of those other players now out
of the picture AJ Brown the Eagles
offense again I know even two Defenders
couldn't slow down that guy last week
similar sentiment with Devonte Adams I
think the bigger question mark goes to
this Cowboys team specifically what CD
lamb and Michael Gallup are going to be
doing down the stretch because really in
fantasy the two key factors that we want
and we kind of ignore the second one
sometimes obviously we focus on the
offense how talented is his player
what's their opportunity how many
scoring opportunities they're going to
get during the course of a game but a
player's defense can actually play a big
role in that opportunity factor and see
the land of Michael gallup's case this
Cowboys defense has been so good that
the Cowboys haven't really needed to
keep their foot on the gas as much as
we've seen in past years on offense I
mean Dak Prescott it's still only three
games this year but he hasn't even had
to throw the ball 30 times in any of
those games and we have seen this start
to impact CD lands the total number of
targets now
a lot of times we like to use Target
share and Target share is a great
indicator for a player that's getting
force-fed the football a lot but Target
share and an offense like the Cowboys
the fifth most run heavy offense in the
entire NFL 25 Target share in that
versus 25 the bills offense not quite
the same thing and that has been the
problem for CD in terms of him just not
reaching that top five ceiling that a
lot of people including myself believed
he had coming into this year so CD has
more than eight Targets in just one of
his past five games and Michael Gallup
man doesn't even have 50 receiving yards
or five catches in a game this season so
we can talk about Gallup still coming
back from the ACL and not being his
usual self and I definitely think that's
a part of the picture that said he's not
getting enough opportunities to even
have fantasy managers willing to wait
that much longer for him to get healthy
so CD lamp still someone that's going to
be started you know every single week
he's out there but I will get used to
expecting more of him as a borderline
wide receiver one as opposed to someone
that we were maybe hoping was going to
jump back and in the top five top six
conversation with the healthy Dak
Prescott under Center
from at Uncle what's up UNC would you
start Damien Pierce tonight you're
probably gonna have to man you can say
what you want about the Houston Texans
organization they're probably all going
to be pretty bad things the one thing
that Lobby Smith does well is get Damian
Pierce 20 plus touches no matter what
and last week we even saw a low-key
change in his underlying usage 100 of
the snaps for Damien Pearson two minute
situations so they still feel the need
to get Rex Burkhead Dario gumbawale out
there but again Damien Pierce is as safe
of a bet to get 20 combined carriers and
targets against just about anybody so I
know the potential game script isn't
great but we'll take targets over
carries and honestly those carries
should be a bit easier to come by
against an Eagles defense that will not
have Behemoth Jordan Davis you know in
that interior line of scrimmage for at
least the next four weeks with him on IR
from that Drew miles Sanders and Devonte
Smith for Amari Cooper
I think you're getting the best player
in the trade with the Mari buds close
man if you can't find room on your on
your in your starting lineup for Miles
Sanders and it's just kind of like you
want to go get the best player involved
okay but I would lean towards keeping
the Eagles I know it's annoying when you
have a running back and a wide receiver
on the same team and last week didn't we
didn't really see either guy pop off but
Devonte Smith this year we have seen
them go back to him time and time again
after having these many Duds so I really
think Devonte could be in store for a
nice bounce back performance against a
burnable Texas secondary meanwhile miles
Sanders I'm before last week he was one
of only four running backs at least 15
touches in every single game I know he's
not going to catch a ton of passes and
we'll usually see them bringing boss and
Scott before being too willing to give
miles Sanders you know 20 25 carries out
there but still a top five scoring
offense that we see in Miles Sanders
finally start participating it in terms
of getting the ball into the end zone so
I would keep miles standards and Devonte
Smith unless you're really loaded
because to be fair want to watch Once
Watson is back I'm already probably
won't be inside the positions top 15
more weeks than not
all right guys finish things off here
with tight ends and I'll get to plenty
more of your guys's chat questions so
once again with these charts blue good
red bad trying to make it as easy as you
guys it's possible to figure out and by
the way if you want to see the entire
charts you know future I did tweet them
out from my Twitter account at iheartit
so you can go get those check them out
in the nitty-gritty stuff for yourself
but easiest remaining schedules for a
tight end position Los Angeles Rams and
Tyler Higby Los Angeles Chargers and
Gerald Everett the Jacksonville Jaguars
and Evan Ingram Carolina Panthers Tommy
Trimble and Ian Thomas they just don't
throw the position enough for us to care
too much about this similar sentiment
with the Patriots where hey I'll be
bringing this up immediately if we see
John who Smith or Hunter Henry Miss time
when they're together though pretty
tough to make it happen we've had the
instances over the years Zach urged
Dallas Goddard even Rob Gronkowski and
Aaron Hernandez back in the day those
are really the only time two Titan
offenses that produced two fantasy
relevant tight ends great thing they
have going on in real life but in
fantasy usually just not leave doesn't
leave enough opportunity for either guy
to really boom so focusing on Evan
Ingram someone that let's face it we all
kind of wrote off after his two years
with The Clapper and the Giants offense
just not doing much of anything in 2020
and 2021 but he's starting to come alive
a little bit in this up and down
Jacksonville Jaguars offense
four catches and 40 plus yards in four
straight games for Evan Ingram and it
hasn't been flukey they're basically
using him as a de facto starting wide
receiver with tight ends we're hoping to
usually get a 70 and 80 percent route
rate because they do have to spend time
blocking a lodge as part of their ask at
the position last week though guys 94
route rate for Evan Ingram I mean that
was higher than freaking 70 million
dollar man Christian Kirk had in the
same football game so finishing off this
you know fantasy regular season stretch
they got the Raiders the Chiefs a bye
week and then Ravens lion Titans down
the stretch so I think the big thing for
Evan Ingram again the usage is there we
just need to see Trevor Lawrence get
back to being the guy he was in weeks
two and three when everyone you know
couldn't wait to send out there Doug
Peterson you know meets Urban Meyer Atop
The Jaguars all-time leaderboard uh list
going on so the two and six team I do
think that the Jaguars have been a
little bit better than the record says
they are again if we do get Trevor
Lawrence playing just a little bit more
like that generational Andrew Luck asked
Prospect he's been lied to be I do think
Evan Ingram will be one of the primary
factors in that stretch now on the other
side of things guys some pretty hard
tight end schedules down the rest of the
way we do have the Buccaneers Dolphins
Falcons Ravens and Eagles showing an
awful lot of red so once again Dallas
Goddard you know especially for the
Eagles someone that is just so good with
the perfect usage that I'm not going to
be overly concerned about his you know
tough matchups on paper and the same
point is going to go for the Baltimore
Ravens and Mark Andrews and Isaiah
likely so finishing off the year they
get the Saints second fewest points per
game allowed two opposing tight ends
this year and then a buy and then some
sneaky other tough matchups Panthers
Jaguars Broncos and the Steelers with
Michael Fitzpatrick you know really
bringing in in week 14 a tough matchup
for him so I will say it is a Baltimore
Ravens offense that now has no choice
but to really be leaning on their tight
ends not like they haven't already
League High 98 targets to tight ends
this year I mean the Chiefs I believe
the only other team above 70 on the
season so the Ravens really do throw
their tight ends more than just about
any other offense and they have two
really good ones I don't need to explain
to you guys why Mark Andrews is as
awesome as he is but Isaiah likely is
someone that dies if Mark Andrews misses
this Monday night game against the
Saints with the shoulder and knee injury
it's gonna be awfully difficult to keep
Isaiah likely out of this starting
lineup I think he deserves immediate top
six recognition because he's not just a
backup tight end stepping into the
starting lineup he could be the
legitimate number one pass game option
considering both Mark Andrews and Rashad
Bateman are expected to miss you know
Bateman at least the rest of the season
and Andrew's at least this week so
Isaiah likely could likely be the number
number one pass game option without
these guys in town and just what he was
able to do last week against the
Buccaneers being pff's highest grade
tight end in the preseason I appreciate
my co-host on the PFF fantasy football
podcast Kevin Cole giving him the comp
of saying he looks kind of like Jordan
Reed out there moving around not as you
know the biggest or the burliest tight
end but someone that you actually look
and say dang it looks like a wide
receiver moving around about 240 pounds
instead of 200 so Isaiah likely and Mark
Andrews tough stretch but more than
enough volume I believe for them to
overcome that in flying colors and with
that everybody let's now jump into
personalized fantasy advice presented by
State Farm with a personal price plan
it's all about creating a price just for
you from at Leo terzo Juju Dion Jackson
or Josh Palmer at the flex
if Jonathan Taylor's Gonna Miss This
Game we're going to go with Dion Jackson
as the lead running back for the Colts
remember in week six this was his role
and what did he do all he did was score
the single most points at the position
in terms of full PPR scoring so Dion
Jackson They trust him in the underneath
passing game without name Heinz in
action like Zack Moss Philip Lindsay
these other guys they won't take that
fantasy friendly passed down rule which
I get might not be quite as Vol as I
won't have quite as enough volume excuse
me as it did you know when Captain check
down Matt Ryan was under Center still
though Deon Jackson someone looking at
15 to 20 touches without Jonathan Taylor
in the fold I will take him over Juju
and Josh Palmer this week from at btab
Deontay Foreman or Dion Jackson once
again it's going to come down to the
injuries if both Jonathan Taylor and
chuba Hubbard out of the picture I do
think I'll give the slight nod to
Deontay Foreman here so they treated him
like a legit Workhorse last week those
26 carries and you guys saw the three
touchdowns him to be fair this week
against the Bengals defense events that
slowly but surely starting to lose some
key pieces most recently number one
quarter cornerback shadowbroosier I just
I'm not convinced that Bengals without
Jamar Chaser would be able to put this
Panthers offense in as bad of a position
as we might think otherwise so I don't
expect the Panthers to score 34 points
per game every single week like they did
last time but with both those starting
running backs out sadly I'm more
confident in the Panthers offense than I
am with the Sam Ellinger lead Colts give
me a Deontay Foreman because I think
they're again their opportunity probably
pretty even with both those starters out
from at kpat12 sleeper fantasy winner
from trade deadline so I actually think
there's four key winners from the trade
deadline uh to Circus that we had going
on this year two key handcuffed running
backs that didn't quite exist this time
a couple weeks ago you guys have already
talked a lot about Dion Jackson I think
that's pretty clear right now because
Jonathan Taylor is already hurt and if
we find out he's ruled out tomorrow all
of a sudden Dion Jackson will be inside
the positions top 15 options for this
week the other low-key handcuff winner
is going to be Jeff Wilson with the San
Francisco 49ers now playing for the
Miami Dolphins so look he is one entry
to Raheem mostert let's face it not
exactly the guy but the most outstanding
you know health history going on for him
one injury to most are away from having
the sort of three down role that really
wasn't on his plate in San Francisco
even when Elijah Mitchell was out and
Christian McCaffrey was still on the
Panthers we had Debo Samuel getting a
couple carries Kyle Jewish check doing
Kyle juice check things in an offense
that doesn't like throwing two the
running back as much so Jeff Wilson I
don't expect him to overtake Rahim
mostert's role necessarily but it's
possible we've seen weird things happen
and that handcuff upside one injury away
to Raheem most certain from being in
that top 15 conversation himself so Jeff
Wilson Dion Jackson big time winners to
lesser extents I think George Pickens
and Kadarius Tony probably not available
in too many wave or wires but these are
also guys where Tony hey he's healthy
now he actually has a chance to play in
a real live football game that's hard
not to be excited about that and what
George Pickens taking Chase Claypool out
of that offense I do think he'd have
much better days ahead now that the
Steelers are finally done with that
terrible schedule stretch they had to
unfortunately go through right when they
decide to put Kenny Pickett under Center
from at Allen Christian Kirk or Devin
Duvernay got to go back to Christian
Kirk credit to Doug Peterson for telling
us that they need to get Kirk more
involved and they have 17 targets over
these past two weeks especially for PPR
scoring you're just more so hoping for
doomeday to get a touchdown so Kirk much
higher floor but two good receivers to
have on the squad here moving forward
from at pops the Bonte Smith or Gabriel
Davis in the flex another tough one guys
I'm gonna lean towards Gabriel Davis but
it's pretty close in this one the thing
with Gabe Davis look we know what the
booms are and they are huge so we have
to live with the bus for a bit honestly
pretty close to Devonte Smith and what
we've kind of seen in that offense the
Eagles as productive as they are
throwing the ball we saw those four
touchdowns last week still on offense
that is bottom six in terms of overall
pass play rate meanwhile pretty much
nobody throws the ball more often than
the bills so Gabriel Davis Devonte Smith
similar boom bust players give me the
guy in an offense that's expected to
throw the ball far more often on a
week-to-week basis
from at a fin since Cooks is out who's
the best pickup off waivers Alan
Robinson DeAndre Carter or Darnell
Mooney so it sounds like we're gonna get
Cooper cut back this week and we've
already kind of talked about that Los
Angeles Rams offense just not being the
sort of stuff that we really want to be
dealing with so I am going to lean
slightly towards Darnell Mooney in this
group it's close between a Rob and
Mooney so if you want to go against what
I'm saying I certainly wouldn't be
calling you an idiot or anything like
that but with Justin Fields don't look
now the Bears offense is starting to
catch a stride a little bit four
straight top 12 finishes four fields in
terms of fantasy scoring and yeah a lot
of that has come with his legs but Darna
Moody has started to pop off a bit as
well I would think this would be the
final week to really hopefully get
something out of him with Chase Claypool
obviously not having that much time to
learn the Playbook and get too involved
from at Wolfie which three wide
receivers should I start this week
thielen Juju McLaurin or Jacoby I think
out of that group I'd be sitting Adam
thielen it's great he's still healthy at
this point in the year I know a lot of
people weren't assuming that was going
to be the case but with Juju we've seen
the back-to-back Big Time weeks from the
guy that had a lot of people not me but
a lot of people call him maybe this
year's version of Cooper cup Terry
McLaurin now all of a sudden making
plays every week at Taylor Honda here
under Center and Jacoby Myers guys
mainstream media won't tell you this the
wide receiver 13 in PPR points per game
this year is none other than Jacoby
Myers so he's averaging over nine
targets per game with Matt Jones under
Center in New England right now we have
ramandre Stevenson we have Jacoby Myers
and that's it but hey still two pretty
good assets that are gonna be inside
their positions top 24 far more weeks
than not moving forward and that does
include Myers
from at T Nelson time to drop Cortland
Sutton uh I have it in my home League
man I was thinking about this exact
situation myself earlier it is close
Jerry Judy has actually been more
productive than Cortland sun and their
healthy games together and at this point
I believe we've gotten 11 fantasy points
from Colton Sutton in the last three
weeks combined so it's not ideal that
said I do think this Broncos offense has
some room to go up we talked about them
earlier not having the toughest schedule
in the world here moving forward so I
would try to keep Courtland Sutton if
you can but if it's a matter of like
winning your week or not what or not
winning your week and like he just
physically needs someone to help fill a
flex Spot It Is by again after all I do
think it's reasonable unfortunately to
hit the release button on Coral and
Sutton how crazy time can go you know
just a nine week spam funny how the way
we were talking about him before the
season started from at just Newman
Trader Jonathan Taylor and Gabriel Davis
from DK Metcalf and ramondre Stevenson
is that a w you definitely won Metcalf
vs game Davis I mean we had that injury
scare and that was terrifying and Madre
Stevenson first Jonathan Taylor awfully
close at this point in time so I think
the W part is going to depend on just
how healthy Taylor can be down the
stretch if he's going to miss a couple
games man I do think you have that w at
a minimum though this is a good even
trade you don't see a lot of those so
kudos to you I would say Stevenson right
now is the one I would give the slight
Edge to because I can see again Metcalf
really blowing Davis out of the water
potentially Taylor and Stevenson could
be pretty close honestly regardless of
what goes on with JT
and finally at moneymaker well Devonte
Adams finally step up dude he's been
fine it's a couple Duds and I get it but
the guy was playing through the flu and
that's it's just one of those things man
guys play hurt and we kind of recognize
it in the lead up and then we forget
about it after the game and then we kind
of just uh tend to just not give them
the credit that they probably deserve
for playing through that pain or in this
case the illness in the first place so
look Devante Adams still one of only six
wide receivers in the league averaging
20 PPR points per game it just hasn't
been quite as consistent because he's in
an offense with Derek Carr instead of
Aaron Rodgers throwing under football so
Devonte Adams still very much looking
like the old Damonte Adams when he's out
there not dealing with an illness I am
fully expecting him to continue to be a
top six wide receiver down the rest of
the way like he's been for most of this
season again bad week eight aside so
that's gonna wrap up everybody
appreciate you guys always tuning in the
BR fantasy live with us we are back here
every single Thursday at 5 PM Eastern
always got a different game plan for the
main portion and of course love getting
all your start sick questions so
appreciate the chat tuning with us as
always again I'm Ian Hardis with PFF on
behalf of BR fantasy until next time
take care everybody